la droite sénatoriale a interrogé Gérald
Darmanin en audition ce matin sur le
rôle de la Ligue des droits de l'Homme
donc ce qui s'est passé à Sainte-Soline
la droite c'est naturel qui accuse la
Ligue des droits de l'homme d'avoir
voulu faire casser un arrêté préfectoral
et qui aussi dénonce et bien les
financements publics avec des droits de
l'homme et on a entendu Gérald Darmanin
qui dit je ne connais pas la subvention
donnée par l'État mais ça mérite d'être
regardé dans le cadre des actions qui
ont pu être menées c'est perçu comme une
menace de la lieu-droit de l'homme
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque la droite
sénatoriale a le droit dans dans une
logique de polémique de chercher voilà
ce qui peut fâcher mais que le ministre
de l'Intérieur
puisse envisager même de très très loin
à menacer l'existence par les
financements d'une association qui a été
créée en 1898 pendant l'affaire Dreyfus
permettez-moi de penser que là on est en
train de dépasser les bornes et j'invite
le ministre l'intérieur à avoir un peu
de mémoire sur ce que représente pour la
défense des droits cette idée de l'homme
que nous devons soutenir absolument
[Musique]